[Musik]
tatort deutschland die kranken von bild
mein name ist sky go und ich begrüße
euch zu tatort deutschland dies ist der
zweite teil einer doppelfolge die sich
mit dem sogenannten hermes keller
befasst im ersten teil besucht bild
chefreporter frank schneider fünf jahre
nach der tat erneut die opfer und
ermittler dabei geht der offenen fragen
nach sucht nach neuen erkenntnissen und
dem warum und
erfasst den entschluss die verbrechen
aus der täterperspektive zu ergründen
lassen hiess einen brief geschrieben ins
gefängnis er hat auch relativ prompt
darauf reagiert und mir geantwortet und
jetzt ist aus dem briefverkehr
entstanden dass wir uns treffen werden
dass wir gemeinsam in der jva uns mal
unterhalten können persönlich
zuvor jedoch möchte er die mutter des
täters marcel hesse michael noch einmal
treffen auf der fahrt zur neuen wohnung
von michael spürt frank schneider dem
gedanken nach welche wirkung ein
verbrechen auf die familie des täters
hat sie es auch absolut ein opfer die
ganze familie was der nächste ist auch
ein opfer auch die schwester die auch
alle mit diesen schmerzen sind
schuldgefühle obwohl sie ja nichts dafür
können der hat das angerichtet aber
trotzdem wieder mit leben hätten wir was
verhindern können jetzt wo etwas
erkennen müssen hätten wir vorher etwas
tun müssen ich glaube dass das zermürbt
diese familie auch und sie sind
natürlich auch absolut opfer nicht
interessiert natürlich jetzt hat sie
noch kontakt zu marcel ihrem sohn
magazin sogar möglicherweise im
gefängnis besucht und die ist es ihr in
der zwischenzeit ergangen hat sie diese
tat mittlerweile ein stück verarbeiten
können ist sie mit der situation
klargekommen der bildschirm ist ist
nervös wird die mutter von marcel auch
dieses mal mit ihm sprechen am telefon
klang sie zustimmend doch seine
erfahrung als reporter sagt ihm dass man
sich darauf nicht verlassen kann frank
schneider klingel zur vereinbarten zeit
an der wohnungstür von michael l guten
morgen entschulden
ob sie doch geweckt
[Musik]
ach so
ich weiß ja nicht ob sie kontakt hat
oder nicht
die stimme des lebensgefährten von
michael l wurde von uns unkenntlich
gemacht um dessen privatsphäre zu
schützen ich habe gerade eine tür von
marcels mutter mit dem lebensgefährten
sprechen können auch sie war zu hause
aber sie möchte eben nicht mehr vor der
kamera sprechen sie hat ausrichten
lassen dass sie einfach zu viel schaden
wenn man auch empfinden zu viel
schuldbewusstsein schuldgefühle sie
möchte einfach nicht mehr darüber
sprechen sie hat auch keinen kontakt
mehr mit ihrem sohn sie hat ihn auch
nicht im gefängnis besucht sie will das
einfach nicht mehr sie kann das nicht
verkraftet dass hoffmann ich sie hat
nicht mehr die kraft dazu
zurück nach wanne-eickel in das
reihenhaus von jacksons mutter jeanette
s sie war gut bekannt mit der familie
des killers hast du irgendein kontakt
zur familie von ihrer schwester die mit
der ja ich ganz guten kontakt vorhatte
sie hat ja dich auch so sagt fast gewann
vor ihm
die einmal alle familien dass auch
extrem schwer zu verstehen was er getan
hat wird die ganze familie auch
verstört und runter gerissen
einheitliche vater sondern immer noch
probleme plötzlich her haben und immer
noch nicht damit klarkommen dass ich da
auch in
teilschuld gibt bei
den jungen hat gehen dass james mutter
braucht eine kleine pause wie die in
jains geschwister mit der tat um da ist
ein oder andere größere kind braucht er
tatsächlich noch ein bisschen
unterstützung kommen weil wir halt
von prozess dafür mitgekriegt haben von
einer tastatur für mitgekriegt haben
einzelheiten die halt nicht
so gut getan haben
und der andere mit dem das zimmer
geteilt hat
er ist jetzt wesentlich ruhiger ist ja
früher war vorher beginnt
es dann nach dem da passiert ist viel
ruhiger geworden hat er ja alles und da
ist selbst mit einem schwung sag ich mal
im alter
[Musik]
der bildjournalist möchte noch einmal
auf die person des muscle asse
zurückkommen und legt dafür ein tablet
mit passagen aus gesprächen mit dem
psychotherapeuten dr christian lüdke
bereit wir haben auch damals schon
spurensuche betriebe und wollten
natürlich unbedingt wissen wer ist
dieser masse lese wir sind seine freunde
wer ist wie dem zur schule gegangen kann
die beurteilen wir haben eigentlich nur
aus dem näheren umfeld von der mutter
selbst
guckt also er war irgendwie kriegen
geist erwartet vertrieben hat seine
mutter geschimpft und seine schwester
dann war es ja laut dann hat es gehört
aggressive stimmung
[Musik]
mutter sagt uns schon dass seine
schwester hatte marseille setzte sich
immer wieder beschwert wie bekloppt der
werden gefährlich der er eine gefahr für
sich und andere hat sie immer gesagt
aber das hat keiner wirklich ernst
genommen das haben wir auch von
mitschülern gehört gehen wollte keiner
zu tun haben das war eher ein harmloser
spinner vielleicht war das sogar eine
auslöse dass man als leser einmal
beweisen wollte ich bin gefährlich ich
bin nicht der mann den er lacht jetzt
zeige ich euch mal was nicht alles
machen kann frank schneider spielt eine
interview passage mit dem
psychotherapeuten dr christian lüth gab
soziopathen psychopathen bezeichnet
der damals in diesem fall für uns
analysierte damals sehr treffend wie ich
fand so geschrieben hat das ist eine art
erkrankung ist das
eiskalt sind
berechnen sie haben keine
reaktion auf
das gerät ist man wieder aufhören aber
da fliegt er im grunde genommen drehzahl
aufzunehmen ist witzig er ist derjenige
der das gemacht hat er gerät in einen
regelrechten rausch
jeanette f sieht in dem mörder nur eines
ein feiges würstchen das sich an
schwächeren vergreift um aufmerksamkeit
und anerkennung bolt egal zu welchem
preis
[Musik]
entschuldigung
ein status
also kommt menschen das ist natürlich
nicht gestimmt
das gerichtsurteil im prozess gegen den
doppelmörder marcel hesse ist vor
wenigen augenblicken gefallen
lebenslänglich mit dem vorbehalt der
sicherungsverwahrung
der 19 jährige marcel heesen mörder des
neunjährigen jaden und des 22 jährigen
christopher w wird ein jahr nach der tat
am 31 januar 2018 zu einer lebenslangen
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt schreibt die
bild damals
chefreporter frank schneider blättert in
den betreffenden ausgaben der zeitungen
aus dem september 2018 der prozess ist
damals wirklich von allen menschen
natürlich fieberhaft erwartet wurden
alle wollten diesen killer sehen wollten
es war am ende für uns alle irgendwie
eine enttäuschung der journalist
erinnert sich wir am 8 september 2018
live aus dem gerichtssaal berichtet alle
hatten den auftritt von marcel hesse
hier heute vor dem bochumer landgericht
mit spannung erwartet und als er dann im
gerichtssaal betrat ja weil man
regelrecht enttäuscht er ist ein
schmächtiger blasser kleiner junge
gefühlt noch keine 19 die ja schon ist
er würde sich momentan nicht äußern und
sein anwalt sagte hier heute am rande
des prozesses ich kann ihnen ja
eigentlich gar nicht aus sagen dass das
kann ich den nebenkläger nicht antun
denn wenn er über diese grausamen tagen
spricht man spürt überhaupt gar keine
reue und das gericht urteilt hart ja das
ist ein sehr ungewöhnliches urteil weil
der 19-jährige marcel hesse ist jetzt
nach erwachsenenstrafrecht verurteilt
worden normalerweise werden in
deutschland heranwachsende bis zum 21
lebensjahr nach jugendstrafrecht
verurteilt er ist ja auch vor der
jugendkammer angeklagt gewesen aber die
beiden gutachterinnen es gab zwei
gutachterinnen die ein psychiatrisches
gutachten erstellt haben in dem prozess
und beide haben gesagt nein er ist
ausgereift er wusste genau was er dort
tut es voll schuldfähig und er muss wie
ein erwachsener auch verurteilt werden
er sitzt mindestens 20 25 jahre und dann
gibt es noch diesen vorbehalt der
sicherungsverwahrung und er wird dann
irgendwann in 20 25 jahren beruht werden
und dann wird man feststellen ist er
weiterhin gefährlich oder nicht und dann
wird entschieden ob er noch mal
überhaupt jemals aus darf es kann
wirklich sein dass er nie wieder die
freiheit sehen wird und 60 70 jahren
gefängnis verbringen wird jeanette f
sitzt im gericht dem mörder ihres sohnes
gegenüber
frank schneider überfliegt den artikel
in den alten zeitungen auf seinem tisch
und schüttelt bestürzt den kopf er
versteht den täter bis heute nicht und
das lässt dem journalisten keine ruhe
hat keine reue keine anteilnahme keine
schuldgefühle klar nichts er redet
darüber wie über einen ausflug am
wochenende und das war die sorge des
verteidigers er hat er gesagt die
beweislage ist so eindeutig daran ist
nicht zu rütteln die fotos der opfer
selbst gepostet und alles das will ich
den opfern ersparen das würde das leiden
und den schmerz dieser familien nur
verstärken und
wahrscheinlich hatte damit recht
behalten was man bei dem prozess auch
noch sagen muss dass das gericht
gefühlt auch ein urteil gesprochen hat
was es so noch nicht gegeben hat der
bild-reporter zieht einige mit
schreibmaschine beschriebene blätter aus
einer mappe ist einen brief geschrieben
ins gefängnis er hat auch relativ prompt
darauf reagiert und mir geantwortet
und jetzt ist aus dem briefverkehr
entstanden dass wir uns treffen werden
dass wir gemeinsam in der jva uns mal
unterhalten können persönlich frank
schneider liest ein weiteres mal den
schon so oft gelesen brief von marcel
risse an ihn was der leser hat mir bevor
ich ihn jetzt im gefängnis besuchen darf
mehr oder weniger in seinem brief eine
hausaufgabe aufgegeben das fand ich auch
schon etwas skurril ich kann das man
gerne zitieren oder vorlesen folgendes
geschrieben ich erwarte nicht dass sie
ihren hochgebildeten publikum jetzt
kommt diese wirklich eigenartige
formulierungen solch stark ziselierten
feinheiten klein grauen möchten aber
wenn sie mir aus dem bestreben sich
einen korrekten eindruck von mir zu
verschaffen dieses gesprächsangebot
unterbreitet haben dann wäre es
keineswegs verkehrt wenn sie sozusagen
als grundlagenarbeit mal wikipedia
aufrufen und sich einlesen daran
angefügt ist ein hinweis auf den icd 10
das ist das werk zur internationalen
statistischen klassifikation der
krankheiten unter der nummer f60 1 ist
die schizoide persönlichkeitsstörung
sps aufgeführt sie zeichnet sich laut
wikipedia durch einen rückzug des
erkrankten von gefühlsbetonten und
zwischenmenschlichen kontakten aus dies
äußert sich in übermäßiger
inanspruchnahme durch fantasien und
selbstbeobachtung einzelgängertum und
eine in sich gekehrten zurückhaltung die
betroffenen verfügen nur über ein
begrenztes vermögen gefühle auszudrücken
und freude zu zeigen gibt es eine
krankheit vor zeigt natürlich wie er
tickt wie er glaubt wer am ende ist es
überspielen dass er wahrscheinlich
eigentlich gar nicht weiß und bis heute
auch gar nicht weiß was er angerichtet
hat bei seiner menschen angetan hat
frank schneider ist im auto auf dem weg
zur justizvollzugsanstalt werl in der
nähe von arnsberg er hat er nie
gesprochen er hat bei der polizei zwar
seine aussage gemacht aber dort hat er
sich aber sehr kühl sehr überlegt sehr
naja souveränen gegeben so weit dass in
so einer situation überhaupt möglich ist
die polizei waren das diktiert er hat
die schlimmsten grausamsten details
erzählt aber wie so ein diktat
heruntergebetet völlig ohne heuer ohne
empathie ohne gefühle und etwas und
diese menschen so zu begegnen das sie
nicht unglaublich spannend weil ich mal
sehen möchte der wirklich keine gefühle
hat er keine reue hat er vielleicht
jetzt nach ein paar jahren in des handys
doch vielleicht gemerkt was er
angerichtet hat findet eine
selbstreflektion statt der reporter
kommt an und stellt sein auto ab die jva
ist unscheinbar klar hohe mauern und
zäune umgeben das gesicherte gelände
aber wie ein hochsicherheitstrakt den
man aus filmen zu kennen meint wird es
hier nicht
dennoch ich bin jetzt hier in werl vor
der justizvollzugsanstalt es handelt
sich hier um den bereich der
sicherungsverwahrten das ist ein
hochsicherheitstrakt extra in die jva
sitzen die ganzen personen die
eigentlich nie wieder in die freiheit
soll und dort darf ich ihn besuchen das
hat mehrere monate gedauert besichtigung
bekommen hat ihn zu treffen ich erwarte
mir davon dass er vielleicht doch
endlich etwas über die taten sagt auch
reue zeigt auch vielleicht sagt wie er
sich erklären wie das passieren konnte
und wie er sich vorstellt wie es
überhaupt für ihn irgendwann noch mal
weitergehen soll dann geht frank
schneider zügigen schrittes auf den
besucher ein gang zu die glastür
schließt sich hinterher
[Musik]
jetzt war ich 200 stunden in hinter
diesen gefängnismauern konnte marcel
hesse treffen konnte mit ihm sprechen ja
ich bin noch völlig beeindruckt davon
auch negativ irgendwo zu sehen wie kalt
er mit diesen taten immer noch umgeht
distanziert die er darüber spricht wie
wenig reue schuldgefühle er zeigt das
muss ich mir meine ganzen aufzeichnung
nur einmal anschauen und gucken was im
detail mir alles erzählt hat das ist so
eine masse von informationen gewesen es
war ein beklemmendes komisches gefühl
total interessant zu sehen wie er mit
den taten umgeht oder teilweise eben
nicht mit diesen taten und mit seiner
schuld umgeht und ja es war ein tag der
in meiner zeit als journalisten auch ein
besonderer bleiben wird die autofahrt
zurück in die redaktion nutzt der
bildjournalist dafür um ungefiltert
seine eindrücke zu schildern als ich ihn
dann in einen besucherraum getroffen
habe herrschte sehr großer abstand ihr
mussten beide in entgegengesetzten ecken
des raumes sitzen dazwischen noch
plexiglas scheiben und es war ein
wachmann dabei und eine
justizangestellte die ihn auch
psychologisch bewertet und begutachtet
am anfang war das gespräch sehr holprig
und so nach 23 minuten fühlte ich mich
eigentlich nicht mehr obwohl es da
einfach nur spannend zu erleben wie er
agiert wie er spricht die er auch
versucht immer etwas vorzuspielen und
wirkliche gefahr geht von nämlich aus
also er wird halt einfach wie so ein
harmloses männchen so ein harmloser
spinner wenn man ja weiß was er
angerichtet hat das für unglaubliche
taten er begangen hat er selber
bezeichnete sie mehrfach als grauenvoll
als abscheulich das allerletzte aber man
nimmt es sich nicht wirklich ab das ist
auch so wirklich reflektiert dass das so
ist frank schneider kommt mit dem auto
in einem ampelstopp zum stehen er fährt
sich über die kurze stoppelhaare er
beschrieb dann noch mal die situation
dass er einfach nicht in einem büro
dürfen wollte er wollte etwas machen wo
etwas passiert wo abwechslung ist und
deswegen war die bundeswehr etwas da
sagt er hätte er das ausnehmen können
was er so im privat nach der toll fand
kampfsport ballerspiele
die bundeswehr ihn nicht nahm empfand er
eine totale perspektivlosigkeit
er dachte das leben geht für ihn nicht
mehr weiter wusste nicht wie es
weitergehen sollte und da ein suizid
nicht für ihn in frage kommen er war
dafür zum fall gesagt das selber da hat
es dann überlegt eben den mann aus zu
löschen eine existenz auszulöschen
zurück im büro tippt frank schneider
seine handschriftlichen notizen in
dassel grüne notebook wirklich großes
mitleid mit dem jaden habe ich nie so
raus gehört mit christopher irgendwie
schon weil er war irgendwie nett zu ihm
hat ihn aufgenommen hat ihnen bei sich
schlafen lassen er sprach immer wieder
davon dass ihm diese mutter besonders
leid täte und hat auch mehrfach erwähnt
dass das sehr leid tut dass dino auch
tot sei da war irgendwie mehr mitleid
aber auch da wieder nicht das mitleid
unbedingt mit christoph hat und das im
mittel ein auch wieder mit sich selbst
mit der situation was da alles passiert
ist man merkt eben dass er jetzt
wirklich psychisch gestört ist eine
persönlichkeitsstörung hat aber wenn man
mit ihm spricht merkt man es immer
wieder wie er versucht über den dingen
zu stehen und es aber gar nicht tun der
journalist klappt das notebook zu und
lehnt sich in seinem büro strom zurück
der blick durch das bodentiefe fenster
auf die baumkronen in der straße unter
ihm dann greift er sich das tablet mit
den interviews des psychotherapeuten dr
christian lüdke
einrichtung
das risiko ist eine möglichen
rückfallgefahr und täter der eiskalt
tötet einfach um aus modlos zu töten
nichts war nicht therapieren frank
schneider verstaut die alten bild
ausgaben in einem dicken ordner dann
verlässt er das büro um noch ein letztes
mal zu dragon's mutter nach wanne eickel
zu fahren und hier von seinem besuch in
welt zu berichten
[Musik]
er versucht immer wieder ausleben
ausflüchte erklärungen zu finden er kann
sich mit der tat ich wirklich
auseinandersetzen er will es zum teil
auch nicht er sagte zum beispiel auch
auf die frage warum er denn sich bei den
eltern der getöteten kinder nie
entschuldigt habe bis heute ja was das
denn bringen würde man könnte das ja
sowieso nicht wieder gut machen dann
könnte man sich das doch auch sparen ja
und warum lebt er noch
jetzt aber weiß auch wie viel aktivität
wieder daran teilnehmen kann er hat noch
leben das ist zwar internet
an dieser stelle möchte ich danke sagen
dass wir wieder dabei wart bei tatorts
deutschland bis zum nächsten mal euskadi
mo
das letzte wort in dieser folge jedoch
möchte ich ja net überlassen die vom
bildjournalisten frank schneider auf die
frage was ihr trost spendet antwortete
er heute lehrer werden und
dann ist so ein bisschen stolz
dass er so viele menschen
[Musik]
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone terbrack
produktion fabian schaeffler
drehbuch lutz neumann
redaktion bild frank schneider und
stefan netzeband